let's go to our caller from the 2:01
area code who's calling today from 201
it's me David
yes it is hi I'm Syria and I'm from New
Jersey I'm 16 years old I just wanted to
ask about Kovac 19:00 what's going
around yeah so news came out like about
an hour ago that the Democratic National
Convention is to about mid August and
and now this concerns going over the
November election so what do you think
is going to happen do you think we're
gonna have like mail-in voting like
Pelosi suggested or do you think the
whole election will be moved so moving
the entire election is very complicated
because really what Trump can't move the
election Trump can ask states to move it
because we have an electoral college
system it's really 50 elections that we
have so each of the 50 states would have
to decide to move it now the real
problem is even if you push the election
back from November 6th I believe it's
December 14th there's some day around
midnight December 14th the right around
mid December where the electors have to
vote so Massachusetts can vote later but
on December 14th the electors from
Massachusetts need to go to the convene
on nating Convention and say
Massachusetts elector electoral votes go
to this candidate or that candidate that
is very difficult to move and then
beyond that if you go past January 21
the Speaker of the House becomes
president so it's it's very complex to
really move it
Trump is resisting mail-in ballots
because he knows that mail-in ballots
aren't good for him more turnout more
people voting isn't good for him
and so I don't know what to expect but I
would not anticipate that the
presidential election will be delayed I
think anybody counting on that is likely
to be wrong
you're just saying there's gonna be some
precautions took probably but that's
about it I don't know if it's going to
be it'll be in person voting with some
kind of social distancing measures maybe
more you know the idea of more polling
places seems very difficult to imagine
when you have Republicans in power who
want fewer voting places maybe vote by
mail
we'll be done in a number of states but
not all I don't know but I think all of
those things are more likely than a
postponed election okay thank you for
your input David I appreciate it
appreciate it great to hear from you
Syria from New Jersey very very good